Підстригти газон у сусіда?
Заїхати полагодити машину до товариша?
Коли йдеться про надання дрібних послуг
родичам або знайомим - все чисто.
Навіть якщо отримати за це невелику грошову винагороду -
це ще не є правопорушенням.
Карним це стає, якщо надання послуг поставлене,
так би мовити, на потік і є постійним джерелом доходу.
Трудова діяльність у Німеччині, яка пов'язана
з приховуванням податків і ухиленням від сплати соціальних внесків,
вважається нелегальною.
Німецькою це називається Schwarzarbeit - тобто "робота по-чорному".
У 2018 році німецька економіка не дорахувалася
понад 300 мільярдів євро через тіньові оборудки.
Нелегальна праця особливо сильно б'є по галузях,
де задіяні робітники низької кваліфікації і не так важливо знання німецької мови.
Левова частка тіньової економіки припадає на будівельний сектор -
приблизно третина. Далі йдуть автомайстерні,
громадське харчування, сільське господарство,
готелі, перукарні та служби таксі.
Приблизно 17 відсотків нелегалів працюють у приватних домогосподарствах.
Це прибиральниці, садівники, доглядальниці, няні тощо.
Останніми роками нелегальна зайнятість у Німеччині скорочується.
Це пояснюють економічним зростанням та малим безробіттям у країні.
Нелегальних працівників у ФРН ловлять не поліцейські, а митники.
Звісно, електрика, який час від часу "підхалтурює"
після завершення свого "офіційного" робочого дня,
або прибиральницю, яка миє підлогу в чиїйсь квартирі, зловити важко.
Але якщо йдеться про якусь фірму, яка грішить нелегальною зайнятістю,
то охоронці закону майже напевно вийдуть на слід нелегалів.
Досить буде порівняти обсяг роботи, кількість працівників,
розмір соціальних відрахувань і так далі.
Якщо впіймають, роботодавцеві загрожує штраф
від 5 тисяч до пів мільйона євро.
В особливо кричущих випадках - аж до 10 років ув'язнення,
якщо роботодавець неодноразово і системно використовував
або надавав нелегальну робочу силу з-за кордону.
Але це - найжорсткіше покарання.
Як правило, йдеться все-таки про адміністративне правопорушення,
а тут максимальний розмір штрафу - 50 тисяч євро.
Плюс доведеться сплатити соціальні відрахування -
навіть на прибиральницю, яка приходила раз на тиждень
і отримувала "кешом" 20-30 євро.
Тож, нелегальна зайнятість у Німеччині може виявитися
дорогим задоволенням як для працедавця, так і для самого працівника.
Адже якщо у громадян держав, які не входять до ЄС,
немає відповідного дозволу на трудову діяльність у Німеччині,
правопорушника можуть витурити з країни,
та ще й заборонити на кілька років в'їзд у Шенгенську зону.
Німецькі митники наголошують:
"безвіз" права легально підзаробити в Німеччині не дає.
Втім, як повідомили DW в німецькій митниці,
громадян України поки що не часто ловили на нелегальній праці.